>>> THERE WAS A REMARKABLE
MOMENT IN A NEW YORK COURTROOM
YESTERDAY, AS STEVE BANNON'S
ATTORNEY PLEADED WITH A
MANHATTAN JUDGE TO RELIEVE HIM
FROM REPRESENTING BANNON IN HIS
CHARITY FRAUD CASE.
AS YOU KNOW, THAT IS BANNON
FACING CHARGES FOR ALLEGEDLY
DEFRAUDING DONORS WHO GAVE MONEY
TO A NONPROFIT THAT SAID IT
WANTED TO BUILD A WALL ON A
SOUTHERN BORDER.
PROSECUTORS SAY BANNON POCKETED
THE MONEY.
HE HAS PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
HE MAY NOW BE WITHOUT AN
ATTORNEY.
DAVID SHONE TOLD THE JUDGE THERE
WAS A BREAKDOWN OF COMMUNICATION
AND HE CAN NO LONGER DEFEND HIM,
SAYING THAT THEY HAVE
IRRECONCILABLE DIFFERENCES.
THE JUDGE HAS GRANTED BANNON
UNTIL JANUARY 28th TO FIND AN
ATTORNEY AND TOLD SHONE ONCE A
LAWYER IS FOUND, YOU NEVER NEED
TO COME BACK.
HERE TO DISCUSS THIS REMARKABLE
MOVIE IS DAVID SCHOEN.
GOOD MORNING, DAVID, AND THANKS
FOR BEING HERE.
I GUESS THE FIRST QUESTION I
HAVE FOR YOU, IS WHEN WAS THE
LAST TIME THAT YOU AND STEVE
BANNON SPOKE?
>> WE SPOKE, WE JUST DON'T SPEAK
ABOUT THIS CASE.
I CONCLUDED THAT WE HAD
IRRECONCILABLE DIFFERENCES ABOUT
THE APPROACH TO THE CASE, THE
DEFENSE OF THE CASE, THE
STRATEGY IN THE CASE, THE
RESOURCES FOR THE CASE.
SO THE BEST POLICY WAS NOT TO
TALK ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
I TALKED TO HIM THROUGH A
THIRD-PARTY LAWYER.
I STILL REPRESENT HIM IN THE
CASE IN D.C. AND I SPEAK TO HIM.
>> SO YOU STILL TALK TO HIM
ABOUT OTHER CASES, BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS BORDER WALL CASE
HE'S FACING, YOU SPEAK THROUGH A
THIRD-PARTY ATTORNEY TO TALK TO
STEVE BANNON?
>> YEAH, THERE'S NO POINT ANY
FURTHER IN DISCUSSING ISSUES
SURROUNDING THIS CASE.
WE HAVE VERY DIFFERENT VIEWS OF
HOW IT SHOULD BE HANDLED.
WHEN I TAKE ON A CASE, I NEED TO
BE ABLE TO HANDLE IT IN THE WAY
I SEE APPROPRIATE.
FRANKLY, THERE WAS A BIT OF A
BREAKDOWN IN THE D.C. TRIAL.
I DISAGREED WITH THE TRIAL
STRATEGY IN THE CASE.
WHEN THE TRIAL CAME, I REFUSED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
EXAMINATION OF WITNESSES AND
ARGUMENT.
I JUST HANDLED THE LEGAL ISSUES
IN THAT CASE, EVEN THOUGH I HAD
BEEN HIRED TO BE THE LEAD
LAWYER.
BUT I HAVE TO BE -- SORT OF
FOLLOW WHAT I BELIEVE TO BE THE
APPROPRIATE DEFENSE AND A LAWYER
HAS TO BE IN SYNC WITH THE
CLIENT FOR IT TO WORK
EFFECTIVELY.
THAT'S PART OF THE RULES OF
PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT AS WELL.
>> YOU MENTIONED RESOURCES AS AN
ISSUE AND OFTENTIMES THROUGH MY
REPORTING I'VE SEEN
RELATIONSHIPS LIKE THIS BREAK
DOWN, IT'S OVER THAT, THAT IS
PART OF THE ISSUE, LAWYERS
GETTING PAID.
IS THAT PART OF THE PROBLEM
HERE?
>> NO, FIRST OF ALL, IF IT WERE,
I WOULDN'T SAY SO.
BUT IT'S NOT IN THIS CASE.
WHEN I SAY RESOURCES, I MEAN THE
RESOURCES SURROUNDING HOW THE
CASE IS TO BE PREPARED, EXPERTS,
THAT SORT OF THING.
VERY SPECIFIC APPROACH TO THE
CASE.
BUT I CAN'T GO INTO THOSE
DETAILS, AS I KNOW YOU KNOW, AND
STEVE BANNON MAY WELL BE RIGHT
AND I MAY BE WRONG.
BUT IT'S HIS CASE AND HIS LIFE
AND HE DESERVES TO BE ABLE TO
PROCEED WITH A DEFENSE HE THINKS
IS APPROPRIATE.
>> THE JUDGE SEEMED TO THINK
THIS WAS PART OF A DELAY TACTIC
BECAUSE NOW BANNON HAS UNTIL THE
END OF FEBRUARY TO COME UP WITH
A NEW ATTORNEY.
IS THIS A DELAY TACTIC?
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> NO, THAT'S WHERE THE THING
BLEW UP YESTERDAY, FRANKLY.
THE PROSECUTOR IN THIS CASE,
THEY INVESTIGATED THE CASE FOR
TWO YEARS.
THEY HAD BY THEIR OWN ACCOUNT,
47 EMPLOYEES WORKING ON THE
CASE.
THEY TOLD US -- WE SET A
SCHEDULE BASED ON
REPRESENTATIONS THEY MADE IN
SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER, THEN IN
NOVEMBER THEY PRODUCED A 20
TERABYTE HARD DRIVE UNDER A
PROTECTIVE ORDER WITHOUT EVER
HAVING REVIEWED IT AND THEY
CHARACTERIZED IT AS TWICE THE
PRINT COLLECTION OF THE LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS SO THEY ASKED FOR AN
EXTENSION.
YESTERDAY THEY STOOD UP AND SAID
THIS IS A DELAY TACTIC, WE
ALREADY GAVE THEM 90 DAYS.
THAT'S WHEN I WENT EMOTIONAL.
THEY ASKED FOR THE 90-DAY
EXTENSION AND YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
TOLD THEM WHEN THEY ASKED FOR
IT, YOU SAID, YOU NEED 90 DAYS,
YOU'VE GOT IT.
THAT'S WHAT SET THE JUDGE OFF.
HE CALLED US TO THE BENCH AND
SAID I DON'T APPROVE OF THIS
CONDUCT IN MY COURTROOM AND
YOU'VE INSINUATED I'M UNFAIR.
I SAID LET ME SAY IT FRANKLY, I
THINK YOU'RE UNFAIR.
I SAID THERE WAS NO POINT IN
DRAGGING US UP HERE.
ALL YOU DID WAS HAVE US RESTATE
WHAT I SAID IN MY LETTERS.
THAT WAS THE PROBLEM GOING INTO
THE HEARING.
HE ISSUED AN ORDER SAYING HE
NEEDED DETAILS SHOWING GOOD
CAUSE FOR THE WITHDRAWAL.
HE'S JUST WRONG ON THE LAW.
I SAW IN THE NEWSPAPER THEY
QUOTED HIM AS SAYING I WAS
WRONG.
HE WAS MIMICKING WHAT I SAID.
I'VE LITIGATED RIGHT TO COUNSEL
OF CHOICE CASES FOR MANY YEARS
IN DIFFERENT COURTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
THERE'S NOT A LOT I KNOW ABOUT
MANY ISSUES, THAT'S AN ISSUE
I'VE JUST DONE A LOT OF WORK ON
AND HE WASN'T CORRECT ON THE
LAW.
ANYWAY --
>> I DON'T THINK ANY JUDGE LIKES
BEING TOLD THAT.
WE NOW KNOW BA